Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to Aaron
from Los Angeles? Aaron, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hello. Hello, David. I know you briefly
mentioned this before, but I was wondering if you
were ever planning on doing. I wouldn't blame you
if you don't do a deep dove on this information
in or in communities, particularly the Latino
community in the United States, because I've
noticed, especially around like the Long Beach,
Linwood Downey area of L.A. County, that there's
a lot of this misinformation and propaganda that's
getting spread area and it's a Spanish language.
Television is definitely nervous. It's due to
that. It's usually just fear mongering on most
of the major networks like Univision. So I was
wondering if there if you were ever or if you know
anybody that has done studies on the effect of
this type of disinformation in those communities.
Speaker 1: I don't know of studies and it's a very
important topic. I sort of met this head on when
I did. I think it was like a 12 or 14 episode
election related show in Spanish on the Estrela
network, which is sort of like a competitor to
Univision, but much, much smaller. They're only
on, you know, a small number of markets. And
I was genuinely shocked at the reactions,
and part of the confusion is overall,
the American Latino community is pretty left. I
mean, Cubans are more right wing. Some Venezuelans
are more right wing, but for the most part, the
American Latino community is pretty left. And yet
there was a ton of like vaccine disinformation and
other things I told my stories of when I was in
Miami a couple of months ago, and like multiple
Cuban, Uber and Lyft drivers were talking about
becoming magnetized from the vaccine and all
sorts of conspiratorial stuff. That's anecdotal.
But but it goes to what we're talking about
here. I think it's a great topic for a deep
dove. I don't know if we'll do it. Maybe we will.
I don't know if we have the bandwidth right now,
but it is a massive, massive issue and it
should be talked about. And you know, you've got
I think some people hesitate to talk about
it because it feels like they're sort of like
attacking Hispanic people are being xenophobic
or whatever. You know, I'm from Argentina,
I'm an immigrant from Argentina. I'm part of that
group culturally. It's just a reality. There's
a lot of that misinformation that spreading. And
part of it, I think, is that there are not enough
points that are available, which is why
I tried to have a counterpoint with that
short run show that I did in Spanish. But yeah,
it major problem. You're completely right in
identifying it as it's exactly as you describe.
Speaker 3: Yeah, it's yeah, I honestly don't think
there is like a fair counterpoint, and even though
like I do agree that many Latinos tend to be like,
I feel like the culture especially, I don't know,
just from my perspective, as a Mexican-American
is very conservative and from like all religious
aspect. Yeah, it's not even just Catholicism
anymore, like the evangelical movement within
the Latino community has been exploding in this
country, and I feel that like that's really like
that is kind of another toxic thing within itself.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Even though voting wise American
Latinos tend to vote for Democrats, there's a
lot of cultural conservatism that remains and
maybe that's part of the issue that leads to the
disinformation spreading. I think you're probably
on to something there. Well, thanks, David.
My pleasure. Very important topic, appreciate
getting the opportunity to chat about it with you.